in the continuing saga of all the disgusting
and immoral and corrupt things that Republican
Senate majority leader Mitch Mcconnell has
done. He has now blocked election security,
uh, bills and he just so happens to be taking
money from voting machine lobbyists. Nice.
Right? This is a separate story, by the way,
from the totally swamped filling financial
dealings of Mitch Mcconnell's wife Elaine
Chao and her conflict of interest. That's
going to have to be a story for another day.
This is other swamp filling nonsense from
Mitch Mcconnell. Remember Russian hacker successfully
targeted voting machines in 2016 voting systems
in 2016 they're likely to do it again in 2020.
Uh, intelligence agencies agrees, uh, agree.
The intelligence agencies of other countries
agree touchscreen voting machines have no
paper trail. Some have no paper trail, which
makes it impossible to verify how votes were
counted if they were counted who they were
accounted for.
And these electronic voting machines can make
it impossible, not only to find, but even
to correct problems in many cases. There are
ideas about how to stop this. Both Democrats
and Republicans have actually proposed some
of those ideas in legislation. Every single
bill that has been proposed has been stonewalled
by Republican Senate majority leader, Mitch
Mcconnell. And of course, big surprise. It
just so happens that the two biggest voting
machine companies have hired lobbyists at
the federal level who recently have contributed
to Mitch Mcconnell's reelection campaign for
Senate in Kentucky. Just delightful, right?
The system. We have the two companies I'm
talking about, r e s and s and dominion voting
systems between the two of them. Those two
companies supply 80% of the country's voting
machines. They have very significant lobbying
operations historically at the state level,
but they've now hired federal lobbyists. Esns
hired lobbyist peck, Madigan Jones to lobby
the House and Senate.
They have a significantly funded this federal
lobbying spending, uh, dominion voting systems
now owned by a hedge fund based in New York
City. Also started federal lobbying this year
with Brownstein, Hyatt, Farber and Shrek,
a different lobbying firm. Many of the lobbyists
working for both of these companies have donated
to Mitch Mcconnell's campaign and to Mitch
Mcconnell's joint fundraising committee. So
listen, can we prove that Mitch Mcconnell
is blocking election security bills because
of the donations from voting machine lobbyists?
No, that's not the point. And that's by design.
That's how the system is designed. Even if
there isn't actual provable foul play here.
This is a corrupt system that it is even legal
for voting machine companies that tally election
results to go and donate money to elected
officials who are participating in those elections,
which may be tallied by their voting machines
is a sickening but legal status quo and the
way things work in this country.
Last segment, I said we have overcriminalization
in the street crime world in the United States.
We have under criminalization and under prosecution
and under conviction and under penalization
of white collar corporate and political crime
in the United States. Mitch Mcconnell is one
of the most insidious forces in American politics
today and he has been for years and very successfully.
So for Republicans, his role in helping Republicans
control the courts, including his amazingly
successful, if you're a Republican, obstruction
of Obama's supreme court nominee, Merrick
Garland, extremely successful from the point
of view of Republicans. Uh, his continued
involvement in covering up the full truth
in the Mueller report. As we saw from day
one after the bar letter was released and
now standing in the way regularly of election
security, this guy has got to go. There are
unfortunately no serious challengers right
now on the basis of polling at taking them
down in Kentucky.
I know that there is at least one declared
candidate. That candidate from the polling
I've seen is not a standing any chance at
this point in time. This guy's got to go and
as much as we need to get rid of Trump, Mitch
McConnell has become an extremely effective,
um, uh, I don't even know what to call him.
He, he's been an extremely effective operative
for some of the bigger Republican successes
over the last 10 years. It's disgusting
and
most
of
it is legal.